greates everyone I want to end today I
am against the best interests of my
human brain playing the demo for
infliction which is a game I think it
has like 48 hours left on its
Kickstarter mostly made by just one guy
that everyone is talking about being
super terrifying and I love horror games
but I also get scared very easily so
this should be a great time
I'm already I'm already super nervous
okay
that sounds like some kind of
relationship gone wrong situation oh oh
no oh oh boy oh the sound design is good
Oh
which means I'm terrified oh boy okay ah
my people y'all got it ventolin inhaler
let me just make sure this is all
correct just bear with me a second do
not exceed recommended dose thank you
all right making sure everyone's safe
you just move it on up books yes I mean
I'm gonna actually read this I'll
probably take this out of the attic for
you guys who won't be interested feel
free to pause if you want to read along
with me oh that's not good well that's
not good either frankly none of it's
good who are you
oh heck I'm very nervous you guys rods
of power okay
life is a storm first of June 1990 I
asked him today what he does down there
he just stared at me silently and pure
hatred I don't understand how this
happened I don't know him anymore and
sometimes he scares me he spends all of
his time in that basement next time he
does a beer run I'm gonna sneak down
there and look for myself trust Gary
man I'm living with isn't Gary anymore I
have to keep Maggie safe there's nothing
else okay huh deodorant excellent
the door just opened [ __ ]
oh why would you put that there
why would you I don't know if I'm gonna
be able to finish this oh geez oh [ __ ]
okay
Oh God
oh you guys okay let's just walk out of
here [ __ ] ha oh this is very PT God okay
some trucks going on can I actually open
it oh yeah all-seeing eye sick five five
five six six six seven all right I
wonder if I can use the phone
five no oh oh button that's my face it's
printed scribbled out I have this thing
with our games room just so scared of
ever moving the camera
oh I have to turn around okay I'll just
looking away looking away look in a way
okay it's fine it's fine
no it's fine I could turn the lights on
I suppose but [ __ ] that painting [ __ ]
light
turn around
well okay it probably wants me to look
at that painting huh I really don't
wanna do that isn't a little light okay
that one didn't work
Oh somebody died what a grief and loss
I'm good
it's too heavy for me today okay I
imagine this is like all referencing the
fact that there's a child can I just
play see attack on the magic box instead
can I do dad instead that sounds like it
would be great okay I still feel like I
can't go anywhere okay
oh okay is this like a Petey situation
where I'm gonna need to pick up all the
pieces how do I take them though I don't
know how to take things you know
but there's a [ __ ] in there he was
definitely a [ __ ] in there nope alright
uh-uh-uh-uh-uh-uh oh god oh god
[Music]
I'm freaking out I'm not looking at my
TV right now because I feel like this is
one of those situations where when you
can hear her it means she's near you and
I know standing still isn't a way to
beat horror games but I'm feeling like
this is gonna be like a Petey situation
but when I hear her she's near me okay
this garage lights and here would be
[ __ ] great
okay it's a step ladder a wrench seems
like a handy thing to have I don't know
how to pick anything up for Oh yikes
who did that
what does it say I was lettuce backwards
maybe okay that's just like a lot of
locks
all right see if there's anything else I
can grab in here like I can't see
anything open uh-huh
kennel make a nice cup of tea y'all
reckon there's gonna be something spooky
in here cuz I feel like that probably is
oh no just a lot to be and maybe he was
going on beer runs well there are tools
up there but this give me some [ __ ]
isn't it
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you Mira nope god damn and
I okay wait the door was open in the
mirror why why okay I don't know how to
open the door stay like keys on here or
some [ __ ] I still don't even know how to
use anything you know jerk I'm supposed
to stare in that mirror I really don't
want to I really don't want to course
god damnit this is gonna be a jump scare
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
alright alright alright alright well
looking through the door
nothing
nothing happened
can i Blake walk through it maybe
I'm just straight up not even oh [ __ ] oh
okay what okay okay
all right we had creepy basement time
this is only getting better Wow
[ __ ] wonderful big basement Jesus all
right I'm glad I figured that out I
could have taken me a while but I still
just
I don't know what it'd go in here oh
what's that nothing cool
nothing all right just really this is a
really good looking game and also it
feels very polished so props to that
okay this is give me some kind of puzzle
was something missing okay find thing
you think I can move this stuff
confirmed all right
what if I could pick up that acts like
that'll be super nice what if you let me
do that this isn't good just kind of
this can't be good
nothing about this looks good at all
okay okay cilia noise in the background
the sound design is freaking me out
okay I don't want to summon Inspectah I
like definitely don't want to do that
during the live from the creature until
it is crossed over into a reptile drink
every loss job so someone like ate
something
[Music]
what wait I just completed that
objective Oh get out of the basement
yeah well that sounds easy yeah
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] am I
supposed to run from her okay I'm going
I'm going
no [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
[Music]
was I supposed to do what was I supposed
to do
okay [ __ ] maybe that was supposed to
happen
[Music]
if you hearing this
I have seen the face of evil in the
world you know
in the beginning Commons and [ __ ]
I'm very glad that demo was short I feel
like that could have been a lot worse
my not prepared for like an hour-long
situation oh my god alright thank you
guys so much for watching I'll be back
later this week I'm gonna do some no
man's sky streams because the next
update is out so those will be on
YouTube and on miksa I'm still
struggling with twitch support getting
them to fix everything for me but yeah
I'm Alana I'll see you guys next time